That was a really good clap.
Good job, Amy.
Des que j’ai deux ou trois ans, ma mere
ma parlee en Francais.
Dann im universitet, ich habe fur drei Jahren
Deutsche gelernt… aber Ich benutze es nicht…
In researching bilingual brains, that is,
how brains work when someone speaks more than
one language fluently, scientists have found
there are differences.
Bilingual brains activate in different ways
depending on the language they’re speaking,
and and also demonstrate incredible cognitively
flexibility, switching back and forth between
languages in a phenomenon called code-switching.
And a new study has found an interesting link
between language and time: the language you
think in can impact the way you perceive time.
Every language has its specific vocabulary
for organizing the world around us, but when
it comes to time, there are two general categories
this is done: distance, as in crossing an
area, and volume as in a space being filled.
Swedish and English both use physical distances
to express a measure of time.
In English we’d say “a short break”
or “a long wedding.”
We use these descriptive terms as though the
passage of time is a measurable distance.
In Greek and Spanish on the other hand, time
is marked with terms that refer to volume.
In Spanish you'd say "a small break" or "a
big wedding."
So the question the researchers had was whether
people who think about time with distance
or volume measurements have a better sense
of how much time has passed.
To measure this, they had Swedish-Spanish
bilinguals watch a line grow across a screen
or watch a container being filled, the first
a measure of time as distance and the second
a measure of time as volume.
And in each instance the subject was given
a prompt in one of the two languages — 'duración'
in Spanish or 'tid' in Swedish.
The results showed that subjects perceived
time as it’s measured in the language of
their prompt.
When given the Spanish prompt, participants
estimated time based on volume, in this case
how full the containers were.
When they were given the Swedish prompt they
could better estimate time as distance, using
the line’s travel as a marker.
So this might not matter to any of us on a
day to day basis, but it’s interesting to
have some scientific evidence pointing to
how much language impacts the way we perceive
something universal, the passage of time.
And we even found this in our office!
Maybe it’s because I’ve been exposed to
multiple languages.
When I think of a big wedding I think of a
lot of people and a long night.
But other people in our office only think
about the number of attendees.
Language, it seems, can creep in and affect
our most basic senses, from emotions to perception
and, apparently, time.
Which means it’s possible that learning
a new language could change the way you experience
the world… which in itself is wild to think
about.
This episode is brought to you by Squarespace.
Whether you need a domain, website, or online
store, make your next move with Squarespace.
Squarespace is used by a wide range of creatives
and people — musicians, designers, artists,
restaurants, and more.
Start your free trial today, at Squarespace.com
and enter offer code SEEKER to get 10% off
your first purchase.
So this is our human brain, but would the
same thing happen to artificial intelligence?
We talk about giving computers consciousness
in this episode right here.
So who out there speaks multiple languages
and is aware of these different cues for understanding
time?
Let us know in the comments, be sure to like
this video, and subscribe so you never miss
an episode of Seeker.